STEPHANIE WONG:
Hey, it's Stephanie.
And today, I'm super excited
to talk about sharing
and monetizing data using APIs.
Let's get into it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this modern digital world
powered by smart IoT devices,
hundreds of petabytes of data
are generated every second
as consumers increasingly
prefer online shopping,
mobile banking, telehealth,
and other digital services.
On the other hand,
organizations are
looking to harness the
power of this data,
using tools like
Google Cloud BigQuery
to deliver personalized
experiences,
make data-driven
business decisions,
improve organizational
efficiency,
and unlock new revenue.
However, there are
several challenges
in putting data into action.
These include data
residing in silos,
security concerns over
sharing proprietary data,
and the complexity of
monetizing data consumption.
This is where APIs can help.
By packaging data
as API products,
you can create a
standardized way
to aggregate data
across systems,
securely share data with other
teams and external partners,
and create rate plans and bill
for the consumption of data.
Let's take a closer look.
In this demo, we are going
to use Apigee to easily
consume and monetize a large set
of weather data from BigQuery.
So the first step is
to use Apigee to create
an API, which pulls this data.
If you look at this
API proxy setup,
we configured it to fetch all
the necessary weather data
from a BigQuery backend target.
Let's take a closer
look at the API proxy.
You'll see that
there are many things
a proxy can add while fetching
the information requested.
It can secure the
API, do rate limiting,
caching, and get a token to
authenticate the BigQuery API.
And on the return flow, you can
reformat the BigQuery response
so that it's easier to consume.
After creating the Apigee
proxy, the next step
is to create an API product.
For this demo, I created
a weather API product.
And you can see that this
product uses the same weather
API that we built earlier.
This product also has a
rate plan associated with it
for monetization purposes.
It helps bill the user
for every API call
made to fetch weather
data from BigQuery.
When you click on
this rate plan,
you can see the pricing
details of $0.12
for every API call made.
Now let's switch
roles and take a look
at how an API consumer would
sign up to use this weather API
and get billed for it.
The first step would be to visit
the Apigee developer portal
and view all the APIs.
Then I can go over to Buy APIs,
pick a subscription that best
suits my requirements, and
review the pricing information.
The next step would be to
create a client app that
uses the Weather API product.
I created an app
called weather-client.
When you click on it, you can
see the Consumer Key, which
identifies this client app.
Now that I have an authorized
app to access the API,
let's test this API and see how
I get billed for consumption.
For that, let's go to
the API documentation
and click on the Weather API.
Here, you can see the
endpoint, required parameters,
body of the API,
and other details.
Let's test out this API.
You can enter the city and
API key that has been granted,
and execute it to fetch all
the weather stations near Santa
Monica from BigQuery.
Let's take one of
these weather stations
and make another API call over
here to get the temperature.
Let's enter the same
API key, choose a year,
enter one of the
weather stations
that we got from the previous
API call, and click Execute.
This gives me the temperature
of every day in 2015
at Santa Monica from BigQuery.
Since I made two
API calls, let's
now see how much I was
billed for this consumption.
Let's go to the Analytics view
and look at the custom report
I created.
This report shows
the overall traffic.
If I chose a specific
developer, you
can see that two
API calls were made
and were billed $0.24,
since each call was
configured for $0.12.
In summary, Apigee
makes it simple and easy
to package your
business data as APIs.
This allows you
to securely share
with other teams and
partners, as well as monetize
for additional revenue.
Now it's your turn
to try it out and get
started by following the links
in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]